People often ask me
what they can do to help
address the climate crisis.
But what they usually mean
is what’s one quick, easy,
simple thing they can do.
Well, that particular ship has sailed.
The climate challenge is gargantuan.
Thanks largely to fossil fuel executives
and the PR firms and politicians
doing their bidding.
We need to eliminate
greenhouse gas emissions
from electricity, transportation,
agriculture, industry and buildings.
We need to protect and restore ecosystems.
We need to change society, policy,
economy and culture.
This is about transformation,
and the stakes for humanity are greater
than my heart and mind can fully fathom.
So I find the best way to cope with this
is to avoid dwelling on the terrifying
scientific projections
and instead pivot quickly to solutions.
Now, the climate movement and the media
all too often ask each of us
to do the same things.
To vote, protest, donate, spread the word,
lower our carbon footprint.
That term, by the way, carbon footprint,
was popularized
by fossil fuel corporations
in an attempt to put the blame
on us as individuals.
But yes, it is good to do those things.
I do those things.
However, all too rarely are we asked
to contribute our special talents,
our superpowers, to climate solutions.
And what a failing.
For that would actually enable
the radical changes we need.
So where do we each begin?
Here's my best answer.
A Venn diagram.
The first circle is:
What are you good at,
what are your areas of expertise?
What can you bring to the table?
Think about your skills,
resources and networks.
The second circle is:
What is the work that needs doing?
Are there particular climate and justice
solutions that you're keen on?
Think about systems level changes,
things that can replicate or scale.
Things like composting initiatives,
insulating buildings, restoring wetlands,
getting climate candidates elected.
And electrifying everything.
There are heaps of options.
The third circle is: What brings you
joy or satisfaction?
There is so much work to be done.
Please do not choose something
that makes you miserable.
This is the long haul.
So it's critical to avoid burnout.
Choose things that enliven you.
The goal is to be at the heart
of this Venn diagram
for as many minutes
of your life as you can.
If you're familiar
with the Japanese concept of Ikigai
for finding your purpose,
you can consider this a simplified,
climate-focused version of that.
Taking this approach will enable
way more progress on climate solutions
than if we each obsess
about our individual footprints.
For example,
nine months after being inspired,
when I took him to his first
climate protest,
Boris Khentov, a financial tech executive,
launched a climate impact investing fund.
And honestly, I don't care if Boris
never goes to another protest again.
Sarah Stillman,
a journalist who covers
systemic injustices in immigration
and worker's rights,
has started including a deep and nuanced
climate context for these issues
in her reporting.
And my own mother,
a retired English teacher,
became a small but mighty part
of getting fracking banned
in New York state.
And is now mothering chickens
and converting her lawn into a model
for small-scale regenerative farming.
I call these climate action Venn diagrams,
and having now seen many of them,
in doing crayon versions by children,
delightfully detailed versions by adults,
this is one of my favorites.
I have a few additional
parameters to offer
before you draw your own.
This does not necessarily mean
you should quit your job,
or go start a non-profit.
Quite possibly, you are most powerful
in your existing roles,
where you already have specialized
knowledge and robust networks.
So how might you lean in to those talents?
Can you help your town,
company, church or school
charge ahead with climate solutions?
Because what we need
is change in every sector
and in every community.
And be gentle with yourself
on the "what are you good at" question.
Set your insecurities aside
and simply consider
what you have to offer.
Over the last year
since I've been sharing this concept,
lots of people have been drawing their
own and posting them on Instagram.
It's been super exciting to see
what people have been coming up with.
But I’ve noticed that a lot of them
are landing on some version of:
“Communicate about climate.”
Now, I fully appreciate the irony,
given that I am standing here
talking to you about climate,
but we can't all just talk about it.
We need doers, we need
mutual aid organizers
and city council members.
We need green building retrofitters
and wind turbine installers
and bike lane planners.
We need culture shapers and policy nerds.
We need employees pushing
their corporate employers to change.
(Applause)
Here's where I will offer
what I consider to be the sexiest word
in the English language:
implementation.
(Laughter)
Because we already have
most of the solutions we need.
We need to get to work
and to pick up the pace.
We need to build the biggest,
strongest team possible
to tackle this most enormous challenge
humanity has ever faced.
Another word I love
that is perfect for this moment
is leaderful.
I learned this term
from Black Lives Matter activists
who use it as an organizing principle.
Social movements can be fragile
when they're helmed
by a few prominent leaders.
We need many leaders
to accelerate this transformation
from a fossil fueled economy
to a regenerative one.
Maybe you are one of those leaders.
Or maybe you don't want to be out front.
That is more than OK.
This is not about being
a hero or an influencer.
This is about being useful.
and advancing solutions.
Contribute to an existing effort,
make it possible,
build the website, raise the funds,
plan the events, recruit the talent.
The question should not merely be,
"What can I do to help
address the climate crisis?"
But, "What can we do together?"
Join something.
And if you need a bit of inspiration,
here is a list of some
climate solutions to consider.
So what will you do?
Or how will you step it up?
Actually draw this out.
What are you good at?
What is the work that needs doing?
And what brings you joy?
Also try to avoid diagramming your way
to what you’re already doing.
Think about this expansively.
Start with a blank slate, and consider
how you can make your best impact.
Remember: this is about action.
I've emphasized the importance
of everyone contributing
to climate solutions.
So before I close,
I want to mention one
of the major barriers to participation.
Inequality.
Perhaps you know that around the world,
it's people of color
who are most heavily impacted
by the effects of climate change,
whether that's air pollution,
hurricanes, droughts or floods.
But you may not know
that it is also people of color
who are most concerned about climate
and most likely to want
to be a part of the solutions.
In the US, where we have
robust data on this,
49 percent of white Americans
are concerned about climate,
compared to 57 percent of Black Americans
and 69 percent of Latinx Americans.
Imagine the huge and additional
contributions these folks could make
if unburdened from the dangerous
distraction that is racism.
And goodness, do we need
all of that ingenuity and leadership.
In other words,
help us, help you,
help us all save the planet.
(Applause)
My last challenge to you, then,
since all our fates are intertwined,
is in addition to leveraging your talents,
can you help others in using theirs?
And let's work to demolish
the societal barriers
that prevent people
from fully devoting themselves
to climate solutions.
This is what I know.
There are innumerable possible futures.
I know we each get some say
in which future we'll collectively have,
and a chance to help build it.
I know that every 10th of a degree
of warming we prevent,
every centimeter
of sea level rise we avoid,
every bit of nature
we protect and restore matters
I know that our actions add up.
This?
This is an invitation.
Find your role if you haven’t already,
encourage others to find theirs.
Averting climate catastrophe:
this is the work of our lifetimes.
Thank you.
(Applause)